Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: TED Translators admin
Mario Fitz: Vamos a aprender a hacer
reanimación cardiopulmonar.
Pero necesito ayuda.
Uno sos vos seguro. Necesito otro.
Diego Golombek: Gerry, ¿estás por ahí?
(Aplausos)
[Ningún Gerry será dañado
en la siguiente demostración]
Voy a necesitar que circules
hasta el centro del redondel rojo
y te desplomes con una muerte súbita
sin lastimarte, por favor.
Diego Golombek, Mario Fitz: Vos podés.
Un aplauso, por favor.
(Aplausos)
Mario Fitz: Gerry, ¿estás bien?
Gerry no me contesta.
Y tampoco está respirando.
Por favor, llamá al 107 y pedí una
ambulancia. Rápido, por favor.
Bueno, como todos saben,
a Gerry no le pasó nada.
Para no lastimarlo
vamos a continuar con la práctica en un
muñeco y le vamos a dar un aplauso
a Gerry por esta gran caída que tuvo.
(Aplausos)
Yo voy a hacer las compresiones cardíacas
para mantener la circulación.
Y te voy a pedir Diego
que si en este lugar
hay algún desfibrilador
vos me lo puedas traer por favor.
Diego Golombek: En el teatro hay
un montón, esperá que te traigo uno.
Mario Fitz: Gracias.
Vamos a prender el desfibrilador
y vamos a hacer lo que nos indique.
“Romper paquete y extraer electrodos”.
Rompemos los paquetes
y extraemos los electrodos.
“Romper paquete y extraer electrodos”.
“Desenvolver un electrodo
del forro plástico”.
del forro plástico”
“No toque al paciente”.
“Analizando ritmo”.
“Aviso de descarga”.
“Cargando”.
“Apártese”.
“La descarga se aplicará en 3, 2, 1”.
“Descarga aplicada”.
En este caso puede pasar,
como lo hicimos rápido,
que él abra los ojos, y pregunte
obviamente “¿qué fue lo que me pasó?”
La respuesta no es
“te moriste, quedate tranquilo”.
La respuesta de tranquilizarlo y ponerlo
siempre con los parches colocados
en la posición de rescate para
que espere a la ambulancia.
Esto es lo que nosotros tenemos
que hacer: ponerlo de costado
para que espere la ambulancia, tranquilo.
Bien, ahora, mientras él espera la
ambulancia, yo les quiero contar
es que en la Argentina hay una muerte
súbita cada 15 minutos.
Entonces, tenemos que pensar que
cuando ocurre esta muerte súbita
ocurre de esta forma.
En cualquier parte,
en personas que se sentían bien
que estaban previamente sanas
y que parecían no tener nada.
Es 200 veces más frecuente
morirse así del corazón
que morirse en un incendio.
Piensen Uds. ahora la cantidad de
matafuegos que hay por todos lados
y, sin embargo, qué pocos
desfibriladores vemos.
Este tipo de muertes inesperadas
en la mayoría de los casos
son producidas por una arritmia.
Esta arritmia hace que el corazón, que
venía latiendo normalmente, deje de latir
y empiece a temblar, provocando la muerte.
El único tratamiento posible es comenzar
con las compresiones cardíacas
para mantener la circulación y utilizar
un desfibrilador para que el corazón
deje de temblar, se resetee, y vuelva
a arrancar y a latir con normalidad.
Si nosotros logramos hacer las
compresiones cardíacas y la utilización
del desfibrilador dentro de los primeros
tres minutos, la posibilidad de que
esa víctima llegue con vida al hospital
es altísima, es del 80 %.
Ahora, si no hacemos nada, casi
ninguno va a llegar vivo al hospital.
Es por esto que tanto las compresiones
cardíacas como la utilización
del desfibrilador forman parte
de la cadena de la vida.
Son los dos eslabones centrales.
Ahora esta cadena de la vida, que tiene
cuatro pasos, tiene tres pasos que están
afuera del hospital, que son Uds. los
que los van a activar porque nadie sale
con un médico en el bolsillo
por si le pasa algo.
Si te pasa algo, el que te reanima y el
que te ayuda es el que tenés al lado;
es por eso que el primer eslabón
es pedir ayuda al 107.
Si Uds. ven que alguien
que estaba normal se cae,
Uds. lo llaman y no contesta
y tampoco respira,
es una situación grave.
Hay que llamar a la ambulancia al 107
o al número de emergencias local.
Inmediatamente tenemos que comenzar con
las compresiones cardíacas que se hacen
en el centro del tórax, en el centro
del pecho, rápidas, fuertes
y sin miedo para que sean efectivas.
Hay que comprimir
el tórax y hundirlo casi 5 cm
para que la circulación pueda funcionar.
Ese es el segundo paso.
El tercer paso es pedir un desfibrilador.
Acá en el Colón hay.
Si me lo traen lo uso
y sigo las indicaciones
del desfibrilador que habla en español
y me dice lo que tengo que hacer.
Y jamás va a disparar
si esta persona no tenía esa arritmia
que provoca el temblor del corazón.
Por lo tanto, nos quedamos tranquilos
porque no va a funcionar
si esa víctima no tiene una muerte súbita.
Ahora si estamos en un lugar
donde no hay un desfibrilador,
continuamos con las compresiones
cardíacas hasta que llegue
la ambulancia, que es el cuarto paso.
Pero la ambulancia va a llegar solo en
tanto y en cuanto en el primer paso
la hayan llamado.
Por eso es muy importante llamar primero
a la ambulancia.
Esto es de tantísima importancia que hoy
lo vamos a practicar todos juntos acá.
Entonces le voy a pedir que ordenadamente
todos se pongan de pie, por favor.
Vamos a –sin golpear al de adelante—
estirar los brazos así –bien estirados—
y vamos a poner la mano hábil abajo
y la menos hábil arriba.
Vamos a entrelazar los dedos y vamos como
a quebrar la muñeca, como a estirar bien
los codos y dejar la muñeca bien expuesta.
Vamos a bajar y con los hombros
le vamos a tirar el peso del cuerpo
sin doblar los codos.
¿Qué vamos a hacer ahora?
A Uds. les dieron una bolsita
cuando entraron.
Dentro de esa bolsa
hay un corazón de gomaespuma.
Vamos a sacar ese corazón y lo vamos
a poner sobre el asiento.
Cuando todos estemos listos,
vamos a practicar
la resucitación cardiopulmonar
con la técnica de brazos
y de manos que les acabo de mostrar
al ritmo de una canción de los Bee Gees
que nos va a marcar los cien por minuto.
El ritmo lo va a marcar una canción.
Entonces, si están todos listos con sus
corazones, cuando yo digo tres comprimimos
a la una, a las dos y a las tres.
(Música)
(Fin de la música)
Muy bien. Un aplauso para
todos estos reanimadores.
(Aplausos)
Ahora nos ordenamos, nos volvemos
a sentar, por favor,
que tengo dos cosas más para decirles.
La primera: los Bee Gees
nos regalaron este tema
para que podamos saber
cuál es el ritmo al que hay que hacerlo.
Porque esta música tiene el tempo a cien
por minuto, que es lo necesario
para hacer las compresiones correctamente.
Quiere decir que si en algún momento
Uds. van a hacer compresiones cardíacas
pensando esta canción lo van a poder
hacer a cien por minuto.
Piensenla nada más, no la canten.
Queda mal, ¿sí?
La segunda recomendación es que Uds.,
antes de hacer las compresiones cardíacas,
tienen que haber sido testigos.
Tienen que haber visto que esa persona
se cayó inexplicablemente.
La tienen que haber llamado.
Que no conteste, que no respire,
haber llamado al 107.
Y recién ahí comenzar
con las compresiones.
No salgan ahora con las manos así
a reanimar a todo lo que está en el piso
porque hay gente que también
está tomando sol.
(Risas)
Bueno, apenas llegás a este círculo rojo
ves un montón de gente.
Yo ahora me estoy yendo
y ya no veo más gente. Veo reanimadores.
Veo un montón de manos que seguramente
en algún momento
van a transformar una situación de muerte
en una situación de vida.
Me voy feliz de haber vivido esto con Uds.
Muchísimas gracias a todos.
(Aplausos)